[Music]
gotta come over here Bobby
[Music]
miss Vangie in the flesh
a legend of season 10 what's it been
like to see the response to you one
episode I didn't need you to say the
entrance one more time I heard a legend
go ahead and say that probably one with
that legend of season Jack miss van G
and the urban legend banjee what's it
been like to see this response I mean
rue war avenging necklace - a Time
magazine event you have been named in
almost every episode of the season what
does that mean to you it's crazy I can't
even wrap my mind around it to be honest
it's all a blessing and it goes to show
you it doesn't matter how long you on TV
[ __ ] make the most of it because who I
didn't think on them is Benji gonna kick
off but baby there you go you got them
cookies yeah I got them cookies i gave
out the cookies and now everybody's
obsessed with miss Vangie I am so anyway
she was moving backwards when you saw
that rule and Michelle liked to do the
Vangie Bay on the show what did you
think of that I thought it was so cute
to see RuPaul like you know like break
out of his character and just start
giggling and it was the cutest thing in
the Michelle's like doing it backwards I
said oh so now you want to now you think
it's funny before when my ass was
getting the boo it wasn't funny but I
live for it I love to see it I retweet
it post it share it comment like
everything else in between
right can we see a back fur maybe season
11 I've got to see more Vangie on drag
race if root ball asked me to come to
clean the toilet or be the pit crew dr.
Khan Chaka Khan or just a ruffle of her
hair I would do whatever mama would ask
me trust and believe miss van G will do
whatever she wanted and she told me to
come out of a box I'll go back in the
box
walk backwards I would do it off will
you ever stop leaving rooms that way no
now why'd they cut my check with that
I'm gonna keep saying it
and so like we need something new I
would say I got you there we go well
congratulations and miss van G yeah
thank you baby I appreciate it
[Music]